[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
البيئه همم يتشارك فيها الجميع ولا ولا
تعترف بالحدود السياسيه البيئه هي يعني
مشاركه بين جميع المرض الله يعطيك مثل
همم العواصف الترابيه التي تتبع الان
المملكه همم غالبيه بالقوسين قالبه
العواصف هي من جنوب غرب العراق عجيب هناك
منطقه متدهوره بيئيه
وتعرضت الاجهاد بيئي
وعندما عند طبعا
النماذج الرياضيه وصور الاقمار الصناعيه
تثبت ذلك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذلك انا اعتقد ان التعاون الاقليمي في
هذا المجال هو الحل
يعني لي ايقاف هذا التدهور في الاراضي
والعيش ضمن مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر في
هذا المناطق الجافه والتي تثير الاتربه في
العراق استفاد العراق اولا ناحيه اعاده
تاهيل البيئه والطبقه الزراعيه والرعويه
واستفاد الدول الجوار ايضا بالضبط
الجار الكبير لهم ربما لا يسمح لهم اللي
هو جار الجار الطيب الجار الايراني
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]